hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
in his essay a conscient approach to
business ethics norman bowie is going to
discuss kant's first formulation of the
categorical imperative which if you
remember runs act always on the maxim
you can will at the same time to be a
universal law of nature and the question
is well how does this actually apply
within the field of business ethics is
this really going to work or not and
bowie will consider some objections and
answer them that have been made to him
by business managers and leaders
i mentioned
that you know kant has this this
particular formulation which is
typically uh
re-articulated by by business ethicists
in terms of
universalization and bowie points out
that not only does does it require that
actions be universalizable
it requires that they be universalizable
without
raising some sort of contradiction so a
prime example of this according to bowie
is kant's own example of making a lying
promise in order to get money that you
need but you have no possibility or
thereby intention
of paying back would it be okay
if i find myself in difficult
circumstances think about for example a
business that's likely to go bankrupt if
they don't get an influx of money coming
in but they they probably won't be able
to pay that money back or a business
that's just trying to extend its
horizons out further so that they can
keep on paying their employees for a few
more months uh you know somebody might
be tempted to say well i'll take out
another loan would that be okay and kahn
says no no it wouldn't be okay
not just because it's wrong in this
particular circumstance but because if
you universalize that practice of lying
to
get some sort of loan making a lying
promise in general what would happen to
promises nobody would believe anybody
because everybody would feel themselves
you know perfectly
uh you know ethical or fine or prudent
if they abandoned the promises that they
made and after a while nobody would make
any promises so it would be in some ways
a self-defeating action on a grand scale
without one actually realizing how
self-defeating that was
bowie provides two other examples that
are particularly interesting
he's got one about stealing on the part
of employees now it might be tempting to
steal just you know because one is one
like stealing one likes benefiting
oneself at the expense of others but
what about an employee who's getting
treated badly
stealing sometimes is a way for them to
deal with their their negative feelings
about the firm and the situation that
they're they're placed in so suppose an
employee angry at the boss for some
justified reason consider stealing from
the firm
can you can you universalize the maxim
which permits stealing and bowie says no
why because goods and services are in
limited supply and universal collective
ownership is impossible so therefore the
institution of private property has
developed when you're stealing you're
taking somebody else's private property
so what you would be saying by
universalizing that as well whenever you
feel upset or whenever you want to you
take the private property of others what
would happen in that situation is the
very notion of private property breaks
down because part of what's in private
property is you keep your hands off my
stuff i keep my hands off your stuff
right so he says if everyone were free
to take from everyone else nothing could
actually be owned the very concept of
ownership would break down
another great example that he gives is
breaking and then renegotiating
contracts playing hardball as we say
from a position of power and he points
out that gm
used to do this quite a lot with their
their uh
suppliers
walmart is is another prime example of a
company that's you know put incredible
pressure to bear on their suppliers as
well so could you
um would this tactic pass the test of
the categorical imperative bowie says it
could not why if a maxim that permitted
contract breaking were universalized
what would happen there wouldn't be any
contracts because a contract is actually
a kind of trust i say i'm going to do x
you say great i'll also do x and you
know or y in in exchange and we both
have to follow through on it if either
one of us can break it and renegotiate
it at any time it's not much of a
contract now is it
um so these are some good examples but
then you know well what you know
what's really going on here he talks
about the test of the categorical
imperative being a principle of fair
play
we have a tendency and kant pointed this
out to make exceptions for ourselves to
say well it's not okay in general but
it's okay in my case it's okay because
i'm under duress it's okay because i
need the money it's okay because i'm
doing it for a good reason and kahn says
we need to get away from this uh
practice of making exceptions for
ourselves and realize that if everybody
did that sort of thing we really
wouldn't have any sort of business
environment to work in
at all
now you could raise some objections and
he does
in fact talk about executives he says
i've used these arguments with
executives who may find them
theoretically persuasive
but nonetheless think that their
practical application is limited in the
real world of business this is a common
issue they said it sounds great
but
how would i actually do this
i you know people do renegotiate
contracts all the time people do steal
all the time people do make lying
promises all the time and bowie points
out something kind of interesting by way
of three different examples he says when
on vacation in ocean city maryland my
favorite seafood outlet had a large sign
on the wall saying we do not cash checks
and here is why below the sign and
nearly covering the entire wall were
photocopies of checks that have been
returned with
insufficient funds stamped in large
letters so what is he pointing out there
a certain threshold had been crossed
this is kind of a practical example of
what happens when a practice starts to
become almost universal it doesn't
actually have to become universalized it
just has to cross a certain threshold or
attain a certain kind of critical mass
and then
you can no longer do that practice
we often frame this in terms of well see
that one that person ruined it for
everybody but it's not one person
ruining it for everybody it's something
becoming a common practice
that ruins it for everybody another
example sort of on the flip side of this
said when lecturing in poland in 1995 i
was informed that shortly after the fall
of communism there was a bank collapse
why because people did not pay on their
loans
experts generally agree one of the
impediments to the development of
capitalism in russia is the failure of
various parties to pay their bills again
if you can't count on people following
through
you can't attain the threshold or
critical mass that's required in order
to have an environment of trust in which
business can actually flourish
another great example that he uses
is that of hong kong he says there's a
lot of speculation
regarding the future of capitalism in
hong kong now that the chinese have
regained sovereignty there
why because hong kong had a legal system
derived from the british that enforced
contracts
the legal system in mainland china is
much more oriented towards political
influence you might say that there's
also a greater degree of corruption
there there's a kind of a balance back
and forth there's always anti-corruption
measures going on which tells you
there's a lot of corruption right so
could hong kong really survive as a
thriving
major center of business practice a
conscientious says would agree with the
economist here hong kong would lose its
premier standing as a commercial center
and suffer economically if it went the
way of mainland china so
each of these doesn't show us
universalization
but it shows us something sort of
tending towards universalization and
this might help us wrap our head around
what conscient capitalism would look
like